I guess the way I want to begin with
this case is to do our analysis of
strategy and key success factors the
gift that is the MIT Salone fellows
program is a year of being immersed in
this environment of curiosity and of
insight this is one of those rare
opportunities that you can jump off the
hamster wheel take time for yourself
think about your life and really find
the path that's right for you and I
think we agree that there's there's a
certain level of technical expertise
everybody brings a unique background a
unique perspective and a unique
objective we have people from the
government people coming from high
fashion people coming from biotech
Telecom any kind of industry
semiconductors scientific
people army navy you're in an
environment where everybody accept
everybody's limitation as opposed to to
agreeing on the Sloan fellows program
does a really good job of showing you
what you don't know about yourself and
about the organization that you're
trying to help move
forward to have 102 type A personalities
with those barriers that typically come
along with a type A personality to come
down it creates an immense learning
environment all his peers were drawing
the organizational chart my classmates
have all come with an open-mindedness
and a desire to enrich themselves as as
individuals with the diversity that
their classmates bring there something
of a culture differential as well the
MIT ecosystem is about freedom of
thought it's about trust and sharing of
ideas brasi's defense is first I'm hard
to find I'm a unique you have a chance
to visit with world-renowned leaders
world-renowned scientists at the same
time the future generation of world Reed
leaders and scientists in a very
unassuming
way
I love to see all the posters about
events on going during the week and try
to attend from from music cultural uh
scientific events it's an ecosystem a
collection of people with different and
diverse interests but with a share ethos
to make a meaningful difference in the
world I think that a big part of the
problem is that it's transformational in
the sense that you come in with one view
of the world and you leave with maybe
five different views of the world
and now I think of this class of more
than 100 people as my friends and as my
colleagues and as people with whom I'll
be in touch for the rest of my life SL
fellows 2012
forever